tout le monde a également en tête les
élections législatives dans un mois à
cet effet françois bayrou va lancer
demain son mouvement démocrate qui va
remplacer l'udf françois bayrou qui se
retrouve bien seul la plupart des
députés udf ont choisi de ne pas suivre
sa stratégie du ni droite ni gauche
thierry curtet guillaume michel françois
bayrou se sentent un peu seuls en ce
moment au lendemain de ces poux de 18%
des voix au premier tour
il était courtisé par tous il annonce
alors qu'il veut fonder un nouveau parti
sur les bases de sa campagne réunissant
jean de centre-droit et de centre gauche
mais il laissait députés libres de
choisir
ils sont 22 à appeler à voter nicolas
sarkozy
ce matin il publie une tribune dans le
figaro que ne veulent plus de cette
stratégie
certains comme françois sauvadet sont
des lieutenants très proche de françois
bayrou on peut pas parler prison chacun
fait des choix dans la vie
françois bayrou vient de faire un choix
il a fait un choix de ne pas voter qui
l'exprimé de ne pas voter nicolas
sarkozy faisant évidemment il a donné un
signe très fort à ceux qui sont venus du
centre gauche
moi je respecte son choix je demande à
ce qu'on respecte notre car bon nombre
de ses députés ont obtenu leur siège
grâce à des alliances à droite ce soir
l'udf réunit son comité exécutif pour
valider la création de mains du
mouvement démocrate des 22 signataires
un seul est venu dans le dernier carré
de fidèles les dents grincent
il ya une chose que je ferais jamais
s'est moqué des électeurs quant au
premier tour
près de sept millions de français se
sont regroupés sur la kawa théâtre sur
bayrou sur le thème précis sur un
renouveau de la politique quand pendant
des semaines et des semaines on a tous
répété qu'on aurait faire de la
politique autrement
moi je vois des choses que je ferais pas
ce soir invité est en crise profonde
à quatre semaines des élections
législatives